welcome to introduction to programming
my name is steven and my name is sean
over the next 90 minutes we'll be taking
you through this series consisting of 21
different segments that hope to cover
the basics of computer programming which
can apply to any and all programming
languages you might want to learn we'll
be starting with the simplest question
of what is programming and from there
we'll be working our way up as we talk
about common features of computer
science such as loops and arrays
we'll discuss how to read and write code
debug code that you've written some
strategies to help you plan out your
code and much much more
the complete list of topics that are
going to be covered in this lecture
style video are shown on the screen now
additionally there will be timestamps in
the description so feel free to skip
around if you are already proficient in
some areas of computer science or just
want to know about a specific topic we
will be covering
hopefully by the end of the series
you'll have a basic understanding of
what computer science is along with an
armory of useful skills that will help
you unravel whichever programming
language you decide to learn first we'll
only be covering the major key points
that apply to all programming languages
so we'll be shying away from topics such
as object oriented coding and command
line navigation as those are things
which are language specific
additionally there will be no software
required for you to download in order to
follow along with this tutorial as we
won't be writing any code in an ide to
keep things simple and concentrated
this video is meant for those who are
interested in computer science and
programming but have no idea where to
start and have little to no background
information on coding and so if that
sounds like you then strap in as shawn
and i work our way through the wacky
world of computer science starting with
the biggest question probably on your
mind which is what even is programming
well the dictionary defines it as the
process of preparing an instructional
program for a device
but that's a really confusing definition
so in layman's terms what exactly does
that mean
essentially it is attempting to get a
computer to complete a specific task
without making mistakes
imagine this for example
you want your less than intelligent
friend to build a lego set except he has
lost the instructions and can only build
based on your commands
remember though your friend is far from
competent and so if they are not given
very specific instructions on how to
build the set there are many mistakes
they could make
if he thinks like a computer then if
there is even one piece that you have
not told him specifically where to place
and how to place it the entire lego set
will be ruined and he will be left to
suffer a complete mental breakdown
causing the whole goal of the project to
be corrupted
giving instructions to your friend is
very similar to how programmers code
instead of a less than intelligent
friend you have a less than intelligent
computer and instead of instructions on
how to build a lego set we are feeding
information on how to complete a program
like a game or a web application
an important thing to note is that
computers are actually very dumb we
built them up to be this super
sophisticated piece of technology when
in actuality a computer's main
functionality comes from how we
manipulate it to serve our needs now
programming isn't as simple as giving
your friend instructions since in a
programmer's case the computer doesn't
speak the same language as you the
computer only understands machine code
which is a numerical language known as
binary that is designed so that the
computer can quickly read it and carry
out its instructions
every instruction fed to the computer is
converted into a string of ones and
zeros and then interpreted by the
computer to carry out a task
going back to the lego example this
process would be like if he was not only
less than intelligent but to make
matters worse he could not understand
english and only speaks in mandarin
chinese
in order to speak with him you have to
convert the instructions that you
understand in english into the language
that your friend understands
this process is essentially what you
must do for your computer in order to
make it understand the instructions that
you give it
the big difference between the two
examples however is that it is very
difficult for people to understand
machine code in binary
directly translating what you want the
computer to do into machine code is
extremely difficult in fact almost
impossible and will take a very long
time to do it if you could
each program is composed of millions
upon millions of those ones and zeros so
how exactly are we supposed to translate
our instructions into machine code
this is where programming languages come
into play programming languages are
fundamentally a middleman for
translating a program into machine code
these languages are much easier for
humans to learn than machine code and
thus are very useful for programmers
going back to our lego example a
programming language would sort of be
like an interpreter that's able to take
the instructions you give them in
english and translate them into
instructions your non-english speaking
friend can understand
this makes programming languages
extremely useful and the backbone of any
good program
think of programming languages as not
english and not machine code but
somewhere in the middle
there are many different programming
languages out there that each have their
own unique uses
languages such as python and java act as
general purpose languages that can
perform a variety of computational tasks
while robot c or html or css are
languages designed for more specific
purposes such as moving a robot or
constructing a website
languages can also vary in how powerful
they are for instance javascript is a
scripting language that is designed for
smaller tasks while java or python can
carry out much more computationally
taxing processes
we can measure a programming language's
power or level by how similar it is to
machine code the series of zeros and
ones we talked about earlier
low level programming languages such as
assembly or c are closer to binary than
a high level programming language such
as java or python
the basic idea is that the lower the
level of your programming language the
more your code will resemble what the
machine can interpret as instructions
aside from the different purposes that
each language fulfills choosing a
language typically comes down to a
matter of preference as are usually many
languages that can accomplish similar
tasks
try different languages and decide which
one's rules interface and level of
simplification you like best
so now that we know what programming is
how do we actually write code it's not
like we can simply type words into a
text document and automatically assume
that the computer can translate it into
machine code read it and carry out a
task like opening up a browser and
additionally we can't just write down
rubbish in certain programming languages
mentioned in the previous segment and
expect the computer to understand so how
are we supposed to write code then
well the answer is with an ide an ide
which stands for integrated development
environment allows the facilitation of
code by a computer ides provide a
graphic interface on your computer in
which the programmer can easily write
run and debug code without having to
worry about problems with complication
or interpretation of the program
think of an ide as any other program on
your computer such as a game a browser
or even the file explorer except we'll
be using it to write code ides are able
to turn your code into machine code and
run it through the computer to produce
results
in addition to providing a place for
programmers to develop their code ides
provides some extremely useful tools for
programmers to ease the job of writing
code such as built-in error checking
because as we'll talk about later code
doesn't always run correctly
auto filling for frequently used words
or phrases and a project hierarchy which
will help you organize and manipulate
the files within your project
back in the olden days before ides code
used to be written on punch cards and
then fed into computers which would take
hours and cause a lot of pain
ides nowadays act as sort of a fast
track to writing code and make things a
whole lot easier for programmers
an example of a specific ide can be seen
on your screen now in the center you can
see the program that is currently being
written and right below it is the
console which can print out useful
information for the programmer
this specific ide is used to write java
code
ides are extremely powerful and will be
used in almost 100 of your programming
projects
so through these ides we are finally
able to write and compile code smoothly
without worrying about the computer not
being able to understand it the next
problem we run into then becomes how do
we write this code in the ide because
it's not like we can just type random
words from a certain programming
language and expect the computer to
understand
this is where a programming language's
syntax comes into play
now just as if you were learning a real
language learning a computer language
can be very similar some have different
styles that may seem odd some may make
you use weird or abstract concepts which
may be confusing and like all languages
programming languages have a set of
rules that you must follow when writing
code in that language and at the
forefront of those rules is grammar
programming grammar is referred to as
syntax and is very similar to real world
grammar each programming language has
its own syntax or rules that you have to
follow to a t if you want your program
to run correctly just as if you were
speaking in real life
these can be things such as how you type
out certain functions what you put at
the end of a line of code and how you
set up certain functions
each language is unique in its syntax
and while some may share similar rules
all will have some quirk which makes it
stand out from the rest
syntax is something that catches a lot
of people off guard since many expect
every programming language to follow the
same set of rules but as we spoke about
in the last segment because each
language is specialized for a specific
task each needs its own set of rules to
function
breaking or disregarding these rules
will result in an error just how
breaking or disregarding rules in real
life will result in an unintended
message
as an example if you wanted to do
something simple such as initialize a
variable which is something that we
haven't covered yet but the example is
still relevant
in java you'll notice how we have to
specify what type of variable we are
defining in this case an integer and
also add a semicolon after the statement
in python we don't even need to define
that we are trying to create a variable
and just have to type what we want to
create
and in javascript we just specify that
we are making a variable but we don't
include what type of variable we want to
make like in java
even in a simple example you can see how
much a syntax matters when learning a
new language since while the goal of our
program remained the same which was to
define an integer with the value 3
all the programming languages shown took
different approaches
all these languages require that you
follow this syntax because remember
computers are extremely dumb if you
forget one semicolon or misplace a
character the entire program will not
run and send you back a syntax error
which is something we'll talk about
later
think of this as if you forget a comma
in a sentence and the entire context of
what you're trying to say gets
misinterpreted
for example in the sentence let's eat
grandma if you were to forget that comma
while it may seem like a small mistake
it changes the entire context of the
sentence making it sound like you're
going to eat your grandma
the same rules follow for programming if
you forget a semicolon the entire
context of your program could be
corrupted and misinterpreted by the ide
now another thing which makes ide so
useful is that they will let you know if
and when there are syntax errors in your
code syntax errors of course being parts
of your code which do not follow the
same rules we talked about previously
the ide will tell you where in your code
the errors and also won't let you run
your program until the error has been
fixed
because of how important syntax is to
writing code and learning a new language
it's recommended that you learn the
rules and syntax of a language before
beginning to write complex programs in
that language
most of the rules are tedious to learn
but easy to master and as soon as you
can do that you'll be able to easily
identify syntax errors and take care of
them easily and be writing code in no
time
that covers the basic gist of syntax and
programming rules so now that we know
how to write code and where to write
code we next need to cover what happens
after we have typed our program and run
our code because writing a piece of code
for a game or for databases is cool and
all but after the computer interprets
the program how will we know what's
happening and whether or not it's
working
well programmers do this by looking at
the console the console is a text
interface within your computer that us
programmers can use for a variety of
different purposes
if you remember a short while ago we
showed a picture of a basic ide
and one of the main parts of the picture
was the console
the main use of the console is to output
text from the program this is usually
done by using a print statement a print
statement is a command that does exactly
what it sounds like it prints text to
the console the print statement is the
first piece of actual code we've talked
about in this series and it's about as
simple as a case the print statement
despite its simplicity is one of the
most important functions in programming
and exists in some form in just about
every programming language
the most basic thing you can ask the
print statement to do is to just simply
make it say something this is done by
instructing the console to print and
then include whatever you want to be
printed inside the parentheses
for example in python the segment of
code print hello world will cause a
message reading hello world to appear
onto the console pretty neat the print
statement is also vital for viewing and
interpreting the computer's output from
a program
for instance
if you tell computers around a simple
calculation
for example to determine what four plus
three is
it will run the program internally and
compute and answer however what is the
purpose of having the computer run this
program if you will not be able to tell
what the result is
instead of simply telling the computer
to perform this calculation instruct the
computer to print the output of the
program to the console and upon the
program's completion 7 will appear on
the console as you can see the console
allows us to easily print information
out to the developer for a variety of
uses
it is important to note that the print
statement varies depending on the
programming language being used for
example in java there are multiple
versions of the print statement
depending upon whether you would like a
line break after the printed text or not
as well as specialized print statements
which make your code run more
efficiently
also the general syntax of using a print
statement and certain nuances of its
function can change between languages
however you can generally rely on it to
carry out the same overall function as
it is foundational statement for
programming in general all of its
functionality makes the print statement
along with the console a very useful
developer tool however it is important
to remember that that is all it is the
developer tool
the console is not really meant to be
viewed by the end user of your program
it tends to be hidden away behind the
scenes and other methods of displaying
information such as displaying text
graphics or images are used to convey
information to the user instead think of
it like this when you are using your
phone you see the console in none of the
programs you use so while you can use
the console to give yourself information
about how your program is performing
don't try to implement it in the final
product because it fundamentally just
isn't meant for that
overall remember to use the console to
its fullest extent when writing and
fixing problems in your programs as it
is a great tool to use to tell how your
program is performing behind the scenes
so now that we know a bunch of
information about programming languages
and how and where to write them along
with the print statement under our belts
let's go over some intuitive things that
the computer can do all by itself
without you having to tell it how to
more specifically we'll be covering some
basic number mathematics as well as
string math
starting off with basic mathematics the
computer already knows how to do simple
arithmetic this includes addition
subtraction multiplication and division
all of which are represented by the
symbols shown on the screen now
in any ide that you may install you'll
be able to print out the answer to
simple math problems using the print
statement which may seem
counter-intuitive because why would you
use the computer to do math when you
have a perfectly good calculator on your
phone
but you have to remember that computers
are dumb and anything we want a computer
to do we have to build up from scratch
basic arithmetic while simple helps out
in almost any program you may write
for example if we wanted to build a
basic calculator app we'd need to
utilize this functionality in order to
correctly display the answer to an
arithmetic problem when our user tries
to add subtract multiply or divide two
numbers
now in addition to the four basic math
equations most programming languages
include an additional operator known as
modulus if this is your first time
hearing this word don't worry since it's
not usually taught in math classes
modulus allows us to get the remainder
of a divisional operation
for example when we take 10 modulus 3 we
are essentially telling the computer to
take 10 divided by 3 ignore the actual
answer and just give us the remainder of
the operation in this case 1.
since when we divide 10 by 1 the answer
is 3 remainder 1.
the 1 in this case is what gets printed
out to the console
if there is no remainder say in the case
that we take 50 modulus 2
since the remainder is 0 the function
would return 0 if we were to print it
out to the console
this can be extremely useful in many
cases the most obvious being if we want
to determine whether or not a certain
integer is even or odd
if we take a certain number modulus 2
and it returns 0 then we know that is
even because any number divided by 2
will always result in a full answer
without a remainder but if the system
returns 1 then we know that the integer
is odd
you will find yourself using the basic
math operators a lot more than you think
so it's good to keep them in mind when
writing your program
now not only can our computer work with
numbers but it can also work with
strings
strings by the way are just another way
to say text
for example hello world is a string the
letter a is a string and anything
enclosed by quotation marks is denoted
as a string in programming languages
we'll cover more about strings in a bit
when we talk about variables but for now
let's continue
we already talked about printing strings
to the console but let's say we're
making a game and we wanted to print out
the statement game over 4 was your final
score
now while we could just make a string
that says that exact phrase and print it
out to the console in some cases it
would be more useful to print out the
actual integer value especially in the
case of a game where the score can
change each time you play because score
definitely isn't always going to be 4.
well we're also able to print out
multiple strings of text and even
integers by adding them together in the
print statement
this is known as concatenation
continuing with our score example if we
wanted to print out the statement
gameover 4 was your final score using 4
as an integer rather than a string we
could do this by breaking down the
statement into two strings and an
integer like so
print game over plus 4
plus was your final score
we of course begin with the print
statement which again will be different
across all languages but in this case
we're using python
inside the print statement we start off
by printing the string game over
now here comes the important part
from there we use a plus sign and add 4
to the print statement just like if you
were adding two numbers
then we can repeat this process with
another plus sign for the final string
was your final score
and we're able to print out the entirety
of our statement easily
doing this we can easily print out
multiple different strings and integers
together in one print statement
we could also combine the two lessons
we've learned thus far and do something
such as game over plus four plus four
plus was your final score
in the case let's say where you have a
game which gives you a base score and
then four points for a certain task that
you completed
this demonstration also displays another
important part of programming which is
that often times to get your program to
be the most efficient you have to
combine aspects of code
now it's important to note that the
computer will take whatever you put in
the parentheses and printed out
character for character so oftentimes
programmers will forget to add a space
onto the end of their strings this can
result in a small mistake in which the
string from the previous example would
be printed out as if to say game over 4
was your final score which isn't that
appealing when displayed on the screen
to the user so it's a good practice to
always put a space after
and before your strings to make sure
this doesn't happen and your string
doesn't end up like that
another important thing to note is the
difference between 4 in quotation marks
and 4 without quotation marks
now four in quotation marks is treated
as a string rather than a four without
quotation marks which is treated as a
number
this may not seem like a big deal but
again computers are dumb and if you try
to do math with a number in quotation
marks it will return an error because
the computer doesn't understand that
you're trying to perform the operation
on a number and it thinks you're trying
to add an integer to a string which is a
big no-no in programming when you're
adding numbers
so when you're programming make sure to
make a mental note of whether or not you
want to make something an integer or a
string because that type of stuff makes
a big difference
alright that concludes our segment on
the base power of computers
now next up we're going to be covering
one of the most important components of
computer science so make sure you pay
attention because next up we're going to
be discussing variables what they are
and how we use them
first of all what exactly is a variable
a variable is simply something that can
store information and can be referenced
and manipulated
think of variables like a cardboard box
cardboard boxes serve as a means to
store items in them which can be changed
out replaced and modified
variables are like cardboard boxes that
store information for the programmer to
reference or manipulate
each variable simply has a type a name
and a piece of information stored inside
of it the type and piece of information
will be covered next and the name is
simply a name for the variable think of
it as writing out a label on the
cardboard box in sharpie
now there are many different types of
variables that a programmer can use but
right now we will just be covering what
are called primitive variables which
include integers booleans floats and
doubles strings and characters
we'll start off by talking about an
integer
an integer or int for short is as simple
as it sounds a variable that can store
an integer value this includes all whole
numbers from negative 2 billion 147
million 483 648 to 2 billion one hundred
forty seven million four hundred eighty
three thousand six hundred and forty
eight
notice how i said whole numbers
integer values can not and will not hold
any decimal values so keep that in mind
when using variables
secondly is a boolean a boolean is very
primitive variable which can store a
value of either true or false
boolean variables can only hold these
two values and are extremely useful for
conditional statements which we will
cover soon the next two types of
variables are floats and doubles
both of these variable types are
floating point data types which
essentially means that these variables
can store numbers with decimal places
whereas integers values cannot hold
decimal values floats and doubles can't
the main difference between the two is
that a float variable can store numbers
of our precision up to 32 bit while
doubles can store numbers with a
precision up to 64 bit essentially a
double can store more decimal places
than a float so it all comes down to how
precise you want the variable to be up
next we have string variables which are
like the strings we've talked about
beforehand except store somewhere in a
value
string variables can store strings of
letters which are just words and
sentences strings are useful for
displaying text and storing input
information strings can also be
concatenated together to form
combinations of string variables and
pre-written strings
this can be very useful for outputting
information in a readable format for the
user for example imagine we have a
string called name the code asks for
input and stores that string of text in
name to output this information to the
user rather than simply displaying their
name you can add the phrase your name is
and make it into a sentence by
concatenating your name is plus name
plus period
this makes it easier to read your code
while also adding variability to your
code which always makes things more
interesting for the end user
finally we have char variables char
stands for character and just as the
name suggests they can each hold one
character this is useful when a
programmer wants to read one button
press or one character in a string
without using a string variable
a specific example is making a game that
is controlled by the keyboard the
program needs to recognize the character
that is pressed and translate that into
carrying out some function
now strings can also hold one character
but charge can hold more than one
character so keep that in mind when
defining variables
now why are variables so useful well
being able to store information in a
format that can be easily referenced
later is essential for any good program
oftentimes in code you're going to want
to keep track of things such as a user's
name or score and so by creating a
variable called name or score you can
store this information in the variable
and then reference it add to it or
modify it
also many times the program will want to
take input from the user which cannot be
pre-programmed into the code and thus a
variable is required to store the
information
a program may also rely on factors that
will change as the program progresses in
which case a variable is once again
required
also taking these variables and
manipulating them is quite necessary for
carrying out many of the tasks you want
to program to carry out for instance
multiplying in variables or
concatenating string variables
overall variables are the backbone of
any good program and you'll find
yourself using them often if you want a
clean and efficient code so it's best
that you learn what types of variables
you need to use and when so now that we
know all about the different variable
types and we've talked about them a
little bit we're going to delve further
into what happens when we actually
define or create a variable how we
reference them and how we can manipulate
them for our programs to start let's go
over what happens when we actually
define a variable now when we write a
line of code which initializes a
variable and that code is executed the
computer essentially creates a little
space in memory that stores your
variable name and its contents so that
it can be referenced later going back to
our cardboard box example from the
previous segment think of this as if you
had your own storage facility and you
make a new cardboard box labeled name
and inside of it you put a piece of
paper with the word null pointer
exception on it now anytime you want to
know the contents of your name box you
could simply look inside and see that it
has the contents null pointer exception
this is what the computer does except
the storage facility is the memory in
your computer the box is a variable and
the contents of the box are whatever the
variable is set to be equal to
anytime you want to know the contents of
the name variable you can simply call it
and the computer will pull the
information that is stored in that
variable and use it how the user see
fits
another thing to note really quickly is
that you can actually make a variable
without putting information inside of it
this would simply be like if you built
up a new cardboard box
gave it a label with a sharpie but just
didn't put information inside of it
you're simply saving that space in your
storage facility for later
this could be maybe because you want to
store information in it later down the
road or if you're going to use it to
store information given to you by the
user in which case you can't give it
information since you don't know what
the user will input
just a note that if you try to reference
or point to a variable which does not
have any information in it you'll get
what's known as a null pointer
nullpointerexception which despite being
an amazing name for a youtube channel is
something you generally want to avoid
when programming
now programming languages allow us to do
some pretty cool things with these boxes
that we've created
for example let's say we created a
second variable called channel name and
instead of setting it equal to null
point or exception we instead set it
equal to our already created name
variable
this doesn't create a space in memory
for this new variable however it simply
points to the same location of memory we
have already created for the name
variable
going back to our storage facility
example this would be like instead of
creating a whole new box labeled channel
name and storing a sheet of paper with
the word null pointer exception on it we
instead simply added another label below
the name box entitled channel name
now we have two variables which point to
the same contents that being the string
null pointer exception we usually do
this to save space in our code for
things that we know are going to have
the same value
variables can also be updated throughout
your code for example let's say you had
an age variable and inside of it was the
integer 17
then you celebrated a birthday and
wanted to update your age all you would
have to do is reference the variable and
set it equal to whatever new integer you
want the variable to hold
in this case 18. this would be the same
as having a box labeled age with a sheet
of paper reading 17 inside of it and
then taking that piece of paper out
erasing 17
replacing it with 18 and then placing it
back in the box
doing this we are able to easily update
the contents of our variables throughout
the code as things dynamically shift as
another example if you're making an rpg
your character would likely have stats
such as attack defense mana etc
as the game progressed you could
continuously update the variables so
that the player could get more powerful
the further along they went through the
game and you wouldn't have to create new
variables
you would simply need to just keep
grabbing that box from your storage
facility erasing and replacing the
numbers on the piece of paper and then
continue along with your code
just keep in mind that these variables
are nothing more than places in memory
in which a certain value is stored so we
can easily update the numbers and the
replace will remain constant
after the code has run its course the
place in memory is deleted until you run
the code again and the program dedicates
space for the variable again
each time you run the code you're making
new boxes in your storage facility and
at the end of the code you destroy them
all to make room for the new boxes next
time
another cool thing you can do with
integer float and double variables is
add them subtract them divide them
multiply them and even modulus them
for example if you were making a
calculator app and you stored the first
number the user entered as number one
and the second as number 2
you could then multiply num1 and num2
together and either print them or store
them in a new variable entitled result
then each time you run the program the
user could input new numbers into the
num1 and num2 variables and they would
simply be set to those new integers that
the user inputted and return the result
that corresponds to those specific
numbers
this allows you to keep easy track of
which numbers are which and what's going
on in your program which is extremely
useful
also while you cannot subtract multiply
divide or take the modulus of strings
you are able to add them like we said
previously let's say you had a string
str1 with the contents hello and a
string str2 with the contents there
you could add str1 and str2 to create a
string that had the contents hello there
either storing it in a third variable or
printing it out to the console
the last topic we'll be covering on the
topic of variables is the naming
conventions of variables which albeit
may seem odd but it's extremely
important when trying to read your code
so we'll be covering it now
now variables have to be one continuous
string and so if you wanted to make a
variable that stored the player's score
you'd have to find some way to combine
the words player and score since you
can't have the phrase player score be
the name of a variable
all programmers have their own personal
preference when it comes to naming
variables but the one we'll be using in
this lecture is called camel case which
is the process of not capitalizing the
first word but capitalizing every word
that follows it
going back to the player score example
using the camelcase method the variable
would be called playerscore this allows
us to easily see and identify each word
and becomes really useful for long
variable names like the player's score
before the final boss
whereas if we just type it out without
camel case it would be really confusing
and hard to read
this will help you out a ton when we
start finding bugs in our code and need
to quickly scan through our program to
figure out what is wrong and adds to the
overall readability of the program
other programmers might use different
naming conventions like using
underscores to separate the words in a
phrase but for now in this series we'll
be sticking with camelcase
next we'll be moving on to conditional
statements which at their core are
statements that change the path of our
code depending on certain conditions for
the sake of keeping things simple for
this section red lines will connote that
our code will not be following the
specific path and green lines will mean
that our code is following the path
the main type of conditional statement
that programmers use is the if statement
and this will show up countless amounts
of times in any program you write
it is as simple as it sounds
if some condition is true
and usually that condition will be
enclosed by braces then carry out the
instructions located within the if
statements brackets
else do another thing
now brackets are used in most
programming languages to indicate a
segment of code which will run
it works like this
if the condition in parentheses is true
then all of the code contained within
the brackets will run and if the
condition within the parentheses is not
true then it will skip over all the
statements within the brackets
a quick note is that while this is the
case with most programming languages
some like python use colons and white
space to determine where a piece of code
starts and ends but for the sake of this
series we'll be using curly braces
now the condition within the parentheses
can take on thousands of different forms
such as if the value of the string
variable name is equal to steven or if
the player's score stored in an int
variable is greater than five the list
goes on and on each of these statements
is evaluated as a boolean which you will
remember from when we talked about
variables is either true or false
if the boolean is true
we run the code inside the curly braces
if it's not
we pretend everything inside the curly
braces never existed and move on with
our code
the if statement comes with two more
additional statements that can go with
it elseif and else
elsif is a conditional statement used
directly after an if statement and
carries out mainly the same function as
an if statement
however the else if statement will only
be evaluated if the preceding if or the
preceding elsif statement is bypassed
due to its condition being false
so we would run through it like so if
something is true
we would run the code inside of that
statement's curly braces
else if that's something is not true but
another statement inside of the
parentheses is true we would then run
that code segment and if neither of them
are true we would skip both segments of
code and move on in our program
this can be a hard concept to wrap your
head around so let's do an example
if we had a program that evaluated the
if statement if age is equal to 10 we
could then have a statement under that
which stated else if age is equal to 12.
now if the age variable was 10 which we
can see from the example that it is then
the code immediately following that
conditional statement in the brackets
would run
the else statement we made will not even
be tested since we know that it is going
to be false
and thus the print statement inside of
that conditional statements brackets
will be ignored and the code will move
on to the rest of the program
now for example let's say we change the
age variable to be 12 instead of 10. now
instead of the first conditional
statement being true it actually
evaluates as false since age is no
longer equal to 10.
so what we do now is first skip over the
print statement which prints out that
age is 10 since it's not and then we
evaluate the else if statement we check
if age is equal to 12 which again it is
and so now we run all the code inside of
that conditional statement before
finally moving on to the rest of our
program
so as a review we check the initial if
statement if it's good then we run all
the code within that if statements curly
brackets and move on with our program
if the initial if statement is not true
we then move on to any else if
statements and evaluate if those
conditional statements are true
we can have as many elses statements as
we want although this could lead to
clutter amongst your code so we'll talk
about some alternatives later to help
this out
now it takes care of the if-else
statement so now we'll move on to the
else statement
the else statement once again comes
after an if or an else if statement and
will carry out its instructions no
matter what as long as the preceding
statement statements are evaluated as
false
if we went back to our previous program
we could add an else statement which
would only have the code in its brackets
wrong if the age variable wasn't 10 or
12. this will catch all cases of the
program that didn't fit into our
parameters
it's a good practice to always have an
else statement at the end of your
conditional statements to catch any
weird cases that may come up in your
program
now remember back to the fact that we
could have thousands of ellis's
statements after a while that can get
pretty cluttered and so another very
useful conditional statement which helps
circumnavigate this problem is a switch
statement a switch statement is
functionally similar to many if and
else's statements together you write a
switch statement in the form of switch
variable and then below that you write
out how many cases the variable could be
for instance if we wrote switch var and
then under we could write out five cases
that the variable var could be and then
the instructions listed under each case
would be carried out if the var variable
would be equal to that case
now switch statements are different
since instead of using brackets they use
a column to signify the start of a set
of instructions and a break statement to
end them this is very useful because you
are able to essentially use many if and
else if statements without having to
write nearly as much
in switch statements you just always
have to remember to include a default
case at the bottom of the expression to
denote any and all cases that don't meet
the above requirements
this simply catches all the inputs that
don't fit within the program's main
cases it's very similar to adults case
at the end of an inference chain
now why are these statements so useful
well many times programmers want their
programs to function differently
depending on different conditions for
instance a program could function
differently depending on the information
that the user inputs such as allowing
user to use a program or not use a
program if they are above or below 18
years old respectively
or in say a video game if a user's
experience is above a certain threshold
we might want to give them harder
opponents to battle
another example could be a program which
changes the color scheme depending on
the time of day or even more simply if a
user presses a button that is meant to
move on to another screen in an app the
programmer would only want that app to
change screens if the user clicks that
button a program without conditional
statements will do the same thing every
time and would be very primitive
compared to one that can change
depending on its conditions
so now that we know how to make and use
variables how to compare them and what
we can do with those comparisons let's
move on to another foundational concept
of computer science and that is arrays
now we've already talked about variables
and how great they are for storing
singular bits of information for making
our code more simplistic but one of the
biggest drawbacks that comes with
variables is their inability to hold
more than one piece of differing
information
for example let's say you're making an
app which allows a user to create a
grocery list
well there's no real easy way to create
lists using variables because it's not
like you can have one variable store the
names of six or seven different food
items remember we can only put one piece
of paper in our cardboard box no more
and besides even if you were able to add
multiple items to one string variable
you would still have a lot of trouble
doing simple tasks you might want from a
list such as searching through it
splitting it or even deleting items from
the list when you're done with them
this is the problem that using arrays
solves for us
an array is as you may have guessed by
now a list you can have an array of
integers an array of strings and even an
array of other arrays which is something
we'll cover in a minute
programmers use arrays when they want to
store a lot of variables containing
information that is all related to each
other such as a grocery list or a high
score list in a game
think of arrays as a column in excel or
google sheets
you have the title at the top and then
below it are a bunch of bits of
information which i'll relate back to
the title
arrays are super useful when programmers
want to store a lot of information that
can be easily searched through because
programmers have developed methods of
breaking down and using arrays to find
specific information in arrays full of
thousands of different variables as an
example to show just how useful arrays
are let's say you're a startup company
that owns an app that has a hundred
thousand users
every time a user wants to create a new
account they input the username they
want and then your program will have to
check to make sure the account name
hasn't already been taken
doing this requires you to search
through the information of all 100 000
of your users to see if that username
has an account with your service
an array would be able to contain all of
this information and make it easy to
search through and find out if the
account name has already been taken with
little to no delay
now the single most important thing to
note about arrays is how you reference
each element of the array within them
let's create a basic array called
numbers and inside of it put the digits
1 through 10.
now when we want to refer to each cell
in this array we would call upon its
index an index is just a fancy way of
saying that number's placed within the
array
now you would think that the first
integer in this array would be the first
index the second would be the second
index and so on but that's simply not
the case
in computer science programming
languages refer to the first cell as the
zero width element in the array
this means that if we were talking about
our array of numbers we just made the
number four would actually be in the
third index five would be in the fourth
and so on so instead of starting our
count from one we start from zero
it's extremely weird and confusing but
it's one of those programming quirks
you're going to have to memorize and
commit to memory
if you were to not follow this
nomenclature and refer to the last
element in this array as the tenth you
get what is referred to as an array out
of bounds error since you're trying to
reference the tenth element but there is
no tenth element what you're actually
trying to do is reference the ninth
element
another extremely important thing to
note about arrays has to do with their
size
when you initialize an array you can do
it at either one of two ways you can
either populate it with the elements
that you want contained in the array
right then and there creating and
filling the array at the same time
or you can define how many elements you
want the array to hold essentially the
array's size and then populate it with
elements later
this is because when we initialize an
array it creates a space in memory that
has a size of exactly what you give it
no more and no less
this is great for when we want to access
elements in the array because we can do
so instantaneously because the computer
knows exactly where in memory the array
is stored but the one downside is that
we can't increase the size of the array
later on all array sizes are final
think of this like setting up a
bookshelf with books
by populating a bookshelf with a certain
number of books and then moving on and
filling the next shelf with different
books we have no way to go back and add
books to that first shelf without
shifting everything over
once we decide how much space to
dedicate for an array in this case
there's no way to add more space
once again because this is extremely
important to remember this means that
once an array has been defined there is
no way to change the size of it if you
have an array titled names with a size
of 8 and you try to add another name to
the array you will receive an error so
be careful when messing around with
array sizes
of course you can always go back to the
start of your code when you initially
make the array and allocate more space
to it increasing its size if you find
out that you need more space to hold
items but once it's defined you cannot
change its size through conventional
methods
another small thing i want to touch upon
really quickly is that when you
initialize an array you must determine
which type of array it is right then and
there
for example you have to specifically say
it will be an array of strings or
integers when defining it and also
you're not allowed to mix and match
meaning that you can't have an array
full of integers with a few strings and
some doubles thrown into the mix they
all have to be the same type
now the last thing we're going to cover
on arrays is a little funky and that is
the practice of putting a raise inside
of arrays if you make an array of arrays
it is referred to as a 2d or
2-dimensional array
think of these as matrices if you have
taken an algebra class before now if you
haven't think back to our google sheets
example but instead of using columns we
would add rows as well
so now each element in an array wouldn't
simply just be a string variable or an
integer variable but an entirely new
array with its own set of values and
elements
the way we index these is mostly the
same except we would have two numbers to
index instead of one
we start with the row and then the
column
so a number in the position zero two
would be in the first row three columns
down
in this case the name clint
a number in the position one one would
be two rows down and two columns across
in this case the name chris
you get the idea now you can also make
three dimensional arrays by putting an
array inside of an array inside of an
array but that's a little above what
we're going to be covering so i'm going
to cut it off there next up we're going
to be talking about loops so what
exactly are loops next up we're going to
be talking about loops so what exactly
are loops next up we're going to be
talking about loops so what exactly are
loops next up we're going to be talking
about loops so what exactly are loops
next up we're going to be talking about
loops so what exactly are loops
well as you could probably tell by that
statement right there a programming loop
is a statement that is used to run
certain instructions repeatedly just
like how the opening statement of this
topic was repeated five times loops are
very useful for a variety of reasons for
instance imagine you want to print
something 15 times sure you could just
copy and paste the print statement 15
times but this is really annoying to
have to do it becomes even more
unrealistic when that number goes up to
say 100 or so
now what if instead of rewriting the
same instructions over and over again
you could simply place the print
statement inside of a loop and it will
occur as many times as you would like
now that's the power of loops
with loops we're able to repeat parts of
code multiple times
now there are three different types of
loops that we will be discussing today
and up first is the for loop
a for loop is very useful for situations
like the one described above where you
would like to carry out a certain set of
instructions numerous times the syntax
for a for loop varies depending on the
language however it usually consists of
three parts an integer value a condition
which the integer value must meet in
order to exit the loop and an operation
to modify the integer value as the
instructions inside of the loop are
completed
each time the for loop runs the
operation you set will be performed on
the integer as long as that integer
still meets the condition you set
usually being greater than or less than
a constant value the for loop will
continue to run
eventually when the integer has been
modified by either increasing or
decreasing it to the point where no
longer meets the condition the for loop
will terminate and the code will
continue to run
for example let's say our integer value
is i and we set it equal to zero then we
set the conditional statement as i being
less than three so basically we're
saying that as long as i the variable we
just created is less than three continue
running the instructions contained
within the loop finally we make the
operation i plus plus meaning each time
the loop runs we increase it by one and
inside of the loop let's just put a
simple print statement
now let's run through the for loop we
start with i equals 0.
0 is less than 3 so we enter the loop
and print out hello world now that the
instructions are done we add 1 to i
making it 1.
moving on one is again less than three
so we want to get into the loop and
print out hello world
again we add one to i making it two now
two is still less than three so we enter
the loop again and print out hello world
finally we add one to it once again and
it becomes three three is not less than
three though it is equal to three and so
we don't enter the loop and it
terminates moving on to the next segment
of code
this is a simple example but you can
extrapolate it across programming to fit
your needs
now when using a for loop you have to
make sure to set up a condition that
given the initial integer value and the
operation will at some point not be met
to avoid creating an infinite loop and
crashing your program an infinite loop
occurs when you give a forward loop
condition which will always be met given
the parameters of the program and so the
software crashes for example a 4 loop
beginning at 10 and checking if i is
over less than 0 and then adding 1 to i
at the end of the loop will never
terminate since i will just increase
infinitely
after the for loop is the very similar
for each loop a for each loop or a four
in a list loop in python is used for
iterating through arrays or lists
essentially the loop will go through
each element in the array and carry out
some set of instructions for each value
if you would like to read all of the
elements in an array and compare them to
some value or perform some operation on
them a for each loop is extremely useful
so for example we could have a for each
loop which iterated across an array and
simply printed out the value of each
array location
next up we have the while loop a while
loop will continually carry out its
instructions while a conditional
statement given to it is true this can
be as long as a certain variable is true
as long as a number is less than another
number or while a value is still equal
to another value for example
while loops are different than for loops
in that the loop is not contained within
one statement but stretched out and will
continue to run as long as this
condition is true
like a for loop you could make the
condition such that it will eventually
return false and exit the loop however
while loops will not crash your computer
should you create an infinite loop
in fact it is very common for while
loops to run infinitely as for certain
programs you would like the program to
continually be iterated through instead
of running once all the way through
until you exit out of the program when
programming a game for instance a while
loop would be used to iterate through
your code continually refreshing the
screens the game runs from there you
could perform operations on the screen
to make the game playable
creating an infinite while loop could be
done by simply using the syntax while
true as the condition true will always
be evaluated as true
finally i'd quickly like to cover the
extension of a while loop the do while
loop
do while loops are very similar to while
loops except they will carry out their
instructions at least once even if the
condition is false and then we'll carry
on like a basic while loop essentially
the conditions inside the loop will run
at least once and then if the condition
is still met they will run again and
function as a normal while loop would
as you can see loops in their many
varieties have some extremely useful
functions using them you are able to
perform an operation many times in a row
you can iterate through arrays and lists
and overall decrease the clutter of your
code
next up we're going to be taking a break
from learning about common programming
statements and dive into what happens
when the code we write doesn't work more
specifically we'll be covering the
different types of errors that can occur
when you're programming and what causes
them
now when you're writing code you have to
understand that things aren't always
going to go the way you expected them to
and sometimes the program doesn't always
work as you had intended it to
we programmers call these errors and
while annoying they are always going to
come up in computer science and so it's
best to learn what they are and how to
deal with them
often referred to as bugs errors in
scripting languages can be narrowed down
to one of three types syntax errors
runtime errors and logic errors
all three of which we'll be covering in
today's video
to kick things off let's talk about
syntax errors these are usually the
easiest of the three to solve since they
are oftentimes something that can be
fixed within seconds if you remember
back to earlier in the video when we
talked about syntax and programming
rules we said that if you were to break
the programming rules or syntax that it
would result in an error
well that's what syntax errors are parts
in your program where you fail to meet
the programming rules and so the
computer doesn't know how to interpret
your code this can be anything from
forgetting a semicolon at the end of a
statement in java accidentally defining
a variable with two words instead of one
or even just misspelling the word string
when you're trying to define a string
variable
lucky for you guys these errors are
extremely easy to fix since you just
need to figure out where the error
occurred and what the syntax rule you
broke was
now thinking back to ides we mentioned
that ides are so useful because they do
precisely that they underline the syntax
errors and usually provide helpful hints
as to how to fix them
think of syntax errors as small
misspellings or grammatical errors in an
essay you're writing annoying yes but
not the most infuriating things
another useful thing about ides when it
comes to syntax errors is that the
program will actually restrict you from
running the code unless all syntax
errors are cleared making them even
easier to identify and fix
the second type of error we will be
covering is the runtime error these
errors don't show until you actually run
the code hence the name runtime error
runtime errors are usually caused by a
statement in your code that seems
logically sound but the computer
physically has no way of computing it in
a reasonable amount of time
the most common of these errors is one
which we've already talked about the
infinite loop as a refresher or an
example think of an infinite loop like
this
say you sat your friend down in front of
the tv put on the office and told him he
could leave as soon as michael made it
that's what she said joke
seems pretty simple right
wrong because instead of putting in the
office you put in friends on blu-ray
no michael no an appropriate joke
meaning your friend would be sitting
there for the rest of his life
this is basically what happens with a
computer you give it some condition that
it has to complete before the program
can terminate however you give it no
feasible way to finish that task
this puts the computer in error mode and
most likely will crash your program as
the computer desperately tries to
complete the condition you gave it
as a computer example if we try to have
a program terminate when integer i is no
longer greater than 99 but i is
initially 100 and only ever increases
the loop will never terminate and the
program will crash
to avoid these you generally want to
think through the flow of your code
before running it especially with loops
to make sure that all of your statements
can be completed by the computer
carefully planning out your code before
you begin writing is an extremely useful
practice and something we'll be covering
towards the later part of this video
the final type of error that we will be
covering is a logic error this error is
also pretty self-explanatory a logic
error occurs when the code runs smoothly
without any runtime or syntax errors but
the result that you get just isn't what
you wanted
for example let's say you had a
calculator app and you wanted to
instruct the program to add two numbers
except it multiplied them because you
used the multiplication symbol on
accident
this leads to the sum being 36 instead
of 13.
nothing went wrong with the code syntax
or run time wise the code runs just fine
it just doesn't work as you had it had
headed it to
these are often the hardest types of
errors to debug since most of the time
you'll have no idea why the code isn't
working and certainly not any idea of
how to fix it
this is why it's a good idea to test
your code incrementally don't wait until
you've been programming for an hour
before testing your application or else
you'll run into a lot of logic errors
logic errors can be extremely
infuriating and could cost you a lot of
time making them a huge pain but if you
know how to effectively debug your code
you'll be just fine
speaking of debugging your code that
brings us straight into our next topic
which is how to debug your program
now let's say you have written a program
you think it's ready and you're ready to
test it you've been working hard on this
and you're excited to see it in action
you run the program and wait for it to
run smoothly and efficiently
only it doesn't work
you've encountered one of the three
errors we just mentioned you really want
this code to work but how this is where
debugging comes into play
if the code is giving you an error then
the first thing you should do is read
the error often times for syntax and
runtime errors the ide will print an
error message out to the console
see what line or lines it points to
since those that will be the lines of
the error occurred
and see if you can understand and fix
what the problem is
if the error isn't clear or you've never
heard of it then try googling it as
there are many websites out there such
as stack overflow which serve as forums
to ask and answer problems with code
chances are if you've had a problem
someone else has had the same issue and
there is likely a tested solution
usually when the syntax or runtime error
pops up you should be able to find a fix
for it fairly easily
however as i said before the issue may
arise from some loophole or oversight in
the code you hadn't planned for
beforehand maybe you did something as
simple as multiply two variables instead
of adding them these are logic errors we
talked about previously
these problems usually won't have red
text show up to explain what went wrong
you'll have to figure it out yourself
now there are a few different strategies
that you can use in order to track down
and fix a logic error
first you could use print statements and
the console in order to determine where
the code is going wrong
imagine you have a conditional statement
that will run one segment of code if an
integer x is greater than 5 and will run
another segment of code if not
if in your program x is supposed to be
greater than 5 when the program reaches
this conditional but for some reason the
program is still printing out x is small
you could use a print statement to help
for this problem specifically you could
place the print statement before the
branch of the conditional that would
print the value of x
now when you run the program you know
exactly what the computer is thinking
printing out the value of x just before
the if else statement will let you know
the variable has the value you want it
to have and if it doesn't you know
that's somewhere above that conditional
something went wrong and x was set to a
value you didn't want it to
in this case x is equal to 2 which is
why x is small is being printed out
now that we know what the problem is we
can track down where and when in the
code we modify x in order to solve it
use print stamps to determine where your
program goes wrong and then try to track
down the cause of these issues and solve
them
if you use this strategy make sure you
end up deleting the print statements
afterwards to avoid clutter in the
console
the situation described above could also
be solved using a breakpoint
a breakpoint pauses your program when
the line you place the breakpoint at is
reached
if say you would like the program to run
through a certain conditional and set a
variable based on that conditional but
you are unsure if this actually happens
in your code you can place a breakpoint
inside the conditional path that you
expect to run
upon the breakpoint being reached the
program will pause and wait for you to
continue it through a button press
this signals at the spot in the code
where the breakpoint was placed
in this case the correct conditional
path has been reached by your program
you can then continue the program
knowing that this was or wasn't where
the error in your code occurred
points can be used in conjunction with
print statements in order to both pause
the program and perhaps view the values
of your variables at the moment in time
to give yourself all the information you
could want you can also have multiple
breakpoints to help slowly work your way
through your program and determine where
an error has occurred
a combination of these two strategies
will help you easily determine where in
your code you have incurred a logic
error
next let's go over what to do if you
think you have tracked down the section
of code that causes the problem you may
think you should delete it but it's
likely you put it there for a reason and
you don't want to lose all that work if
you don't have to
firstly try commenting it out
comments are used to markup code and
explain their surrounding sections but
they can also be used to debug anything
that is designated as a comment will not
be read by the program as code and will
be skipped over essentially it becomes
something that is only there for you the
programmer to read
the syntax varies from language to
language but it usually involves placing
some symbols before or around the code
you would like to be commented examples
of how to comment in different languages
can be seen on the screen now
also when you comment something the ide
will grayscale that line of code making
it extremely easy to determine what's
commented and what's not
commenting code deletes it in the
computer's eyes without actually
deleting it
if a problem is present before you
comment a section of code but it is gone
afterwards then that section of code is
the culprit if you comment part of the
code out and there are still issues then
move on to another section until you
find the culprit once you do you can
tweak it until it works as intended or
delete it entirely and you'll have a
fully functioning program once again
now that we've talked about what to do
if you've encountered an error and a
strategy on how to find and fix it i'd
like to talk about some strategies you
can use to avoid errors in the first
place
firstly back up your code frequently in
the event of the code completely bugging
out and you being unable to fix it
you'll want the ability to revert to a
previous version where the code was
still working
if you save frequently enough then you
will probably not lose too much work
version managers like github or
subversion can help with this as they
backup code to an online cloud service
in which you can easily pull previous
versions of the program from at any
point
also on top of saving run your program
frequently to ensure that the current
version works as intended this
accomplishes two things first of all it
prevents you from saving a backup that
doesn't work
secondly if you encounter a problem it
will be easier to find if you have only
made a small number of changes since the
last time you ran it and it worked and
thus you will only have to look through
the new code for problems if you've
spent five hours coding and hadn't run
it during that time period it's going to
be likely that at some point during that
five hour code session you messed up and
it's going to be even harder to figure
out where you went wrong
errors while annoying and extremely
frustrating are a fundamental part of
making you a better programmer
alright now that we've covered errors
for a bit let's hop back on the
programming statement train and talk
about one of the most important concepts
in computer science the function
now you may not know it but we've
actually been talking about a few
functions this entire series
print statements for loops and even the
basic math operations we've talked about
are all examples of functions which of
course begs the question of what
actually defines a function
well a function is a segment of code
that can be easily run by calling the
function name and depending on the type
of function will do something in return
functions can be called numerous times
and in numerous places in your code
essentially they are like wrapping up a
segment of code into a nice present and
giving it a name which when called will
unwrap the present and go through the
code that you had wrapped up
for example the print statements we have
been using this series allow us to print
something to the console anytime we want
those are functions
you see we just call the print function
and enter in what we want to be printed
to the console into the parentheses and
the computer does it for us
behind the scenes there is actually even
more complex code that is in charge of
taking your text and translating it to
the console to be printed
the developers of almost all programming
languages realize that you don't want to
program something that manually has to
print something to the console through
the use of complex programming and so
they implemented the print statement to
reduce the stress and complexity of code
on the user abstracting it to the single
line of code that is print
all of that code that is used to print
something to the console is wrapped up
like a present and given to us in the
form of one line
this is actually the main theme of all
functions and the backbone of any good
program
oftentimes in your program there are
going to be sections of code which are
repeated and serve the same purpose or
equations which you want to allow
differing inputs of and so you can use
functions in order to condense these
down into singular lines of code to save
both time and reduce clutter on your
code
as you will see soon functions are
extremely powerful and will definitely
be something you utilize all the time in
your computer science journey
the print statement is just one example
of functions in everyday code there are
thousands of function that are available
to you through the ides however because
we won't always use all the functions
that are available to you in a single
program you have to import these
functions from packages found in the ide
which is something that we'll be
covering later on
now there are four main types of
functions in most programming languages
and they are separated by two defining
features whether or not they take in
arguments and whether or not they return
values
let's start by separating them by
whether or not they take arguments but
first we have to cover what arguments
actually are
arguments are essentially variables that
we pass into the function in order to be
manipulated and then either returned
back to us printed to the console or
used in another operation
think of functions with arguments like
this
if you walked up to your local five guys
and told them that you wanted to get
food without supplying a type of food
they would probably look at you confused
in order to get the food that you want
you need to tell them exactly what you
want to order so that they can give it
to you
in this case getting food is the
function and what you order in terms of
food is being passed in as the argument
based on what you tell them or the
argument that you pass into the get food
function they will do something
different
you should also note that the argument
can be many different things it could be
fries burgers sodas really anything on
the menu and such is the case with
arguments in programming
arguments can be strings integers arrays
pretty much anything
as an example of a function that takes
in arguments
let's look at the max function which
takes in two integers as arguments and
returns the maximum number between the
two
now for this function if you don't input
two numbers or variables for it to
compare it's going to throw you an error
just like the five guy's employee he
doesn't know what you want to eat since
you didn't provide him with any
arguments and the computer doesn't know
which two numbers you wanted to compare
and return since you didn't provide it
with two integers
arguments are a way for programmers to
have one function that can do many
different things depending on whichever
variables can be passed through
arguments add variability to programming
and can help diversify your code
think of it like this a restaurant that
only allows one type of food to be made
regardless of what you order isn't going
to be very useful or diversified but if
we're able to pass in arguments and tell
them what food we want our experience
can be heightened and more options can
become available to us which is exactly
what happens when you start using
arguments in your function
now that we've talked about functions
that take in arguments let's move on to
functions which do not because functions
can also be created and used without
taking arguments in and still be
incredibly useful to the programmer
for example let's say you're making a
text-based rpg game and one of the
options you give your player is the
ability to view their stats at various
points throughout the game
now every time you come upon this option
and they choose the view stats button
you don't have to type out six different
print statements for every statistic
they may have
your code would get cluttered and messy
very quickly
instead what you could do is you could
package the six different print
statements in a simple function called
print stats
you don't need to pass in any arguments
into the function since the function
will do the same thing no matter what
the statistics on the player are
now every time the user wants to view
their stats you could simply call the
print stats function and voila the user
stats are printed for them to view
this allows you to save a lot of time
writing code but also a lot of space
which is extremely important when your
programs begin getting into hundreds and
thousands of lines of code and you want
to easily search through it to maybe
debug
okay now that we've separated functions
into those that take arguments and those
that do not let's again split these up
into those return values and those that
do not
now the thing you have to understand is
that when you're making your own
functions which is something that we'll
be covering very soon you have to choose
what your function will return if
anything at all
functions are able to return values back
to the user whether they be in the form
of string variables integer variables or
even arrays
now the thing to note about returning
variables is that calling the function
alone won't do anything you have to
return the value into something or print
it out
as an example the max function we talked
about previously would return an integer
back to the user but in order to do
something with it we would have to
either set a new integer variable equal
to the result of that max function or we
can print out the result of the function
which in this case which is print out
the maximum value between the two
integers
using functions which return values
don't do much on their own you have to
pair it with something in order to gain
the use from it let's do another example
let's say you had created a function
which took in two string variables as
arguments and combine that using that
fancy string math we talked about
earlier
and then return them as a singular
string
this combined string function could then
be used to create new string variables
since what it returns is basically a
string
the variable would simply be set to
whatever is returned from this combined
string function
the last type of function is one that
does not return anything and these are
known as void functions
oftentimes these are like the print stat
functions that we created earlier
simply used to condense large amounts of
print statements that appear often in
your code these cannot be set to
variables since they don't return
anything and just get the code that's
within them run through
so there you have it the four types of
functions ones that take in arguments
and return something ones that take in
arguments and don't return something
ones that don't take in arguments but
still return values and ones that take
in arguments and don't return anything
each of these four types of functions
are useful and unique in their own way
and you will probably find yourself
using each of them through your
programming journey so get used to the
different types of functions and know
how to make the most of them as they are
all extremely powerful
finally i'd like to talk about one of
the major benefits of functions which is
that it makes it super useful to make
large changes to your code without
having to go through the entire program
each function call is essentially just a
copy of that function's original code
and so it's very easy to make changes to
that initial function and have it
translate across your entire code
let's go back to our print stats
function and say that you wanted to go
back and add in a new statistic that the
player could level up and through
experience in the game
without functions you would have to go
back into your code and find every
instance that you'd printed out the
user's stats and create another print
statement to display the new statistic
however if you had created a print stats
function like we did just a while ago
all you would need to do is find out
where you define that function and add
in a print statement which displays the
new statistic and you're done
now every place which you would
previously call the print stats function
will now also print the new statistic as
well
you can see just how powerful functions
can be if used properly and we haven't
even scratched the surface yet
now up next we're going to cover how we
can import other people's functions that
they've written and use them in our code
now before we get technical close your
eyes and imagine you are trying to build
a house
sure you could grow your own trees drop
down your own wood make your own tools
and nails and build it from scratch
but why do that when you can simply go
to your local home depot and buy these
materials that others have already made
ready for you
that's the main idea behind importing
functions into your code
importing functions allows you to gain
access to libraries of functions that
other people have already made for you
this is just as useful as it sounds
there are so many functions that are
super useful for any given program that
it would take you forever to write them
all yourself
luckily other people have already done
most of this for you
in each programming language you are
able to use an import statement to
import libraries of functions into your
program that you can use as you write it
a library is simply a collection of
functions that all have the same theme
it may be a math library a data analysis
library a library which translates text
or anything you can think of really
there's such a variety of libraries for
any given language that most functions
you require that are not hyper specific
to your program can likely be found in
some library
in fact a good portion of any
programmer's job is looking online for
packages which can make his or her job
easier instead of handwriting functions
now i can hear you saying
wow that's sick
how do i do it
well it's quite simple an import
statement
in most languages an import statement
consists of three parts the library you
would like to import from
the package you would like to import
from that library and then which class
from that package you would like to use
for example we can load up the java
library and from there import the util
package short for utilities
and then from that utilities package
import the scanner class a class which
allows us to read information from the
user a package is simply a smaller set
of functions and methods to help
differentiate between the thousands of
methods contained in a library and a
class is even more specialized than that
now if you don't know what specific
classes you're going to want to pull
methods from
you can use a star to import all classes
within the package you'd like
however it can be beneficial to be more
specific and only import the classes you
would like as it helps with the
efficiency of the program in the long
run
for instance in python the syntax to
import a library is import followed by
the library name
however importing an entire library is
more computationally taxing than
importing specific functions from a
library
imagine you would only be using the
factorial function from the python math
library it would be a waste of computing
power to import the entire library and
it would increase the load time for your
program for smaller programs this isn't
a big deal but it really starts to add
up when dealing with larger projects
therefore you would instead use from
math import factorial or the java
equivalent import java.math.factorial
and now have access to that one math
command only
this limits the functions that you can
use however it saves programming runtime
if you decide you want to use another
function that you hadn't planned for you
can always go back and import that too
many times if you try to use a function
from a comment package and you have not
yet imported it the ide will prompt you
to do so if you're trying to figure out
which libraries you want to import think
of the functions you're going to need in
your program perform a simple google
search and you will probably run into a
package or library that already exists
in your ide that you can use
and if you can't there are ways to
download and import additional projects
to fit your needs but what if after all
that you still can't find a library that
contains the function you're looking for
well that's a perfect segue into what
we're going to talk about next which is
the basic structure for writing your own
functions
so at this point we've talked about both
what functions are and how we can get
some very useful functions by importing
them through packages but they're
definitely going to be moments in your
programming career where you're going to
want to make your own functions because
you want one to be made specifically to
your program and code
luckily making your own functions is
extremely simple there are just some
basic rules that i want to cover
now while we've previously used making
functions as an example for other topics
such as the player stats function from a
little bit ago they were extremely
abstract and didn't go into depth into
what is needed for an actual function to
operate so right now we're going to be
covering a skeletal system of everything
that needs to be included in a function
in order to get it to work
now think back to the four different
types of functions that we talked about
previously
functions that do and don't return
values and functions that both do and
don't take in arguments
for creating your own functions we're
just going to have to go down the list
and talk about how to approach creating
each one of them starting with the most
basic of the bunch
one which takes in no arguments and
returns no values
before we start that there are a few
small things i want to note about
function naming conventions
the variable naming conventions we
talked about previously also translate
over to function names so you can't have
two word functions and you can't use
special characters like periods or
commas
generally you're going to want to follow
the same camel case style which we
talked about in the variables video
which is not capitalizing the first word
but capitalizing each word after that
all right so in general for making
functions each language differentiates
on how you tell the computer that it's
actually a function
in java you have to define the function
scope which is something you don't
really need to know unless you're going
to become more invested in java but
basically it tells the computer which
parts of the code can use the function
and which type can't
for this series all of our functions
that we make are going to be public
from there you then determine which type
of function it is so in this case since
it won't be returning any variables
we'll just put void to signify this type
of function will not be returning
anything
finally you put the function name after
those two identifiers along with a set
of parentheses after it like so
the parentheses are where your arguments
would go if you were making a function
that took in arguments but since for our
first type of function we're not
incorporating arguments into this
function let's just leave those blank
all of that is just for java
python on the other hand all you have to
do is put the word def short for define
and then the function name with a set of
parentheses
so as you can see each language is going
to be a little bit different in how you
make functions but the main thing we
want to remember is to always add
parentheses
from there we just type what we want our
void function to do within the confines
of the function and close it off and
we're done
in java the confines of the loop would
be whatever is contained within the
curly braces and in python it would be
until you are no longer indented
at its core this is the most primitive
type of function we've made
something which takes in no arguments
and returns no values
quite similar to the print stats
function from early on
moving on to the next type of function
creating a void function that takes in
arguments now this process is going to
seem very similar to the previous except
for one small adjustment
remember the parentheses that i
mentioned earlier
well we put any variables we want the
user to pass into the function into
these parentheses and then when we call
that specific function it will be
required to have those variables passed
into it
for example in java let's make a
function that takes in two numbers and
prints out the product of those numbers
we start with the public void plus name
of function set up again since we won't
be returning any values and here comes a
new part
inside the parentheses you define which
type of variables you would like to pass
in as arguments in this case an integer
and then a name for that variable this
name is what you will use to refer to
the integer that the user passes in
for example let's just call it num1
then if we want to add another argument
we simply add a comma in between the two
and we can make another integer variable
num2 to hold the second number
we could do this for however many
variables we want to pass into the
function but for now let's close off the
parentheses and just print out the
product of num1 and num2
as you can see we refer to the two
numbers that the user will input into
the function as num1 and num2
whatever numbers that the user passes
into the function will be converted into
num1 and num2
now whenever we want to call the
multiply numbers function we just have
to make sure that we are putting two
numbers in as arguments in this case the
number 5 becomes num1 and the number 8
becomes num2
from there we simply run the code and
the number 40 is printed to the console
it's pretty important to note that you
can also mix and match variables when
making arguments so you can have some
function which takes in a car an integer
and two strings all within one function
the last thing i want to mention about
arguments is that when you call a
function you have to follow the
variables you defined when making the
function so for our multiply numbers
function you couldn't put in a string
and then an int it has to be two
integers because that's what the
computer is expecting to be passed into
the function
so now that we've gone over how to make
functions that don't return variables we
have to cover those that do and we'll
start with ones that don't take in
arguments
now the main difference between defining
functions that return variables and
defining ones that do not is that in
some cases you have to specify that you
want this function to return an integer
variable
this is most common in java where you
would replace void with int to tell the
computer that you want this function to
give you something back to you in the
form of an integer
this works the same as if you wanted to
return a string
care or even an array
you simply replace the word after public
with whatever variable you want to be
returned by that function
the most important thing to remember
about making functions that return
variables is that no matter what path
your code takes it must return a
variable no matter what
what does this mean
well let's say you had some string
function in a game and inside of it
there was an if statement where if the
player score was above 10 you returned a
congratulatory message
this works fine if you printed the
results of this function and the
player's score is above 10 but if the
player score was less than 10 then you
don't enter the if statement and then
you don't have something prepared to be
returned to the user and so the function
is going to throw you an error
you have to have all your paths covered
which may seem simple but if you're
making a function with a switch
statement in it containing high amounts
of cases then this can get out of hand
very quickly
something i like to do to make sure this
doesn't happen is put a return statement
at the bottom of a function with a
string or an integer so unique that i'm
able to tell that the code is not
running properly and can fix it
also usually an ide will let you know if
there is a path in your code or in a
function that does not return a variable
when it should
the main point i'm trying to get across
however is always cover your exits and
make sure you have a return statement
prepared for any case the user may throw
at you
another small thing to note is that you
can't return one type of variable if
you've already defined the function to
return another type for example you
can't return a string in an integer
function or vice versa the return
statement must always match the type of
function no matter what
the final type of function is one that
returns variables and also takes in
arguments and for these all you need to
do is combine what we've learned from
the previous cases first you assign your
arguments in between the parentheses
making sure that you have also defined
what type of variable you want to return
and then ensure that no matter what path
the code takes that you're always
returning that variable type
that concludes our discussion on
functions as you can probably tell
functions are an extremely vast subject
area and require a little bit of
practice to fully understand
which is why later on in this series
we'll recommend some websites you can
use to practice those more difficult
topics
now i'd like to switch gears a little
bit and continue our discussion from
earlier on arrays
arrays while useful aren't the only way
to store and manipulate information
fact there are a multitude of different
ways to store data in computer science
including linked lists stacks
cues
maps
trees and many others too
right now though
i'd like to talk about two cool wacky
and zany ways to store data that we
haven't previously covered array lists
and dictionaries but before we get into
those let's get a little review and
reinforcement of arrays
as you may remember arrays are basically
lists of values that are stored together
when you initialize an array you give it
a size and this size is fixed you won't
be able to increase the size of the
array so when you make an array its
length is final
to access the values in an array you
reference them using an index which
starts at zero
what this means is that the first item
of an array is not at position one it is
at position zero
and its position is commonly referred to
as its index location
so to find the nth item in an array you
would refer to it as index location n
minus 1.
however
as the size of an array is fixed you
have to be careful to not reference a
position that is beyond the total size
of the array or to append too many items
to it as this will return an error we
also have what are known as two
dimensional arrays which is an array
containing an array at each of its
indexes
or you could have an array containing
arrays containing arrays containing
arrays containing arrays depending on
what you're trying to do
multi-dimensional arrays can be useful
in more advanced programs for organizing
a wide volume of related values
if that's confusing at all skip back to
earlier for our full discussion on
arrays the timestamp will be in the
description
now that we've reviewed arrays let's go
over array lists array lists or just
lists in python can be thought of as a
growing array
earlier we mentioned how you have to be
careful to set an appropriate size of
your array and to make sure that you
only reference and append values such
that you remain within the size however
with array lists this isn't a problem
after you initialize an array list it
instinctively has a size of 10
but if you append values such that the
size of the array list goes beyond 10
elements an array list will grow itself
meaning that the computer will allocate
more memory to the array to increase its
total size so that the new values can be
appended
this is quite useful when you don't know
the exact number of values that the
array will need to store or you want the
ability to store more values to your
heart's content such as when you're
making a database with an unknown amount
of users that will sign up there is a
lot more to uncover when regarding a
write lists but for this surface level
series that is all you pretty much need
to know so let's move on to dictionaries
now when we're talking about
dictionaries we're not referencing that
thick book you probably have lying
around your house which has thousands of
definitions in computer science
dictionaries are like arrays in that
they store multiple values however their
values are stored very differently
rather than being referenced by their
linear position within the dictionary
each value is tied to another value that
is used to reference it or its key
because of this we need to throw away
all conceptions of dictionaries as a
linear way of looking at data since in
actuality it is much more fluid and
interchanging
basically we say that each position in a
dictionary holds a key value pair
when referencing a value in a dictionary
you will use its unique key and the
dictionary will tell you the value that
it is tied to think of it like this
each time you add an item to your
dictionary your computer creates a
handcrafted box to store the data and
also custom makes a jewel key one of a
kind no other like in the world this way
there is only one key that goes to the
box that stores a certain bit of
information
because each key must be unique reusing
the key in the dictionary will result in
an error being thrown because having two
keys that are exactly the same would
confuse the computer as to what box or
piece of information that key leads to
however you can store the same value in
multiple key value pairs since the keys
would all be different now like i said
dictionaries are more fluid making them
easier to organize than arrays as
everything is set up in a more logical
manner
that is to say it is easier to find the
value you are looking for when you are
using keys rather than simply
referencing their positions
let me explain what i mean
imagine you have a dictionary of prices
at a store where the key is the name of
the product and the value is the price
of the item
maybe apples cost one dollar milk costs
two dollars and bread costs three
dollars you can see that in the
dictionary each key is the name of a
product and each value corresponds to
the price of each product so to find the
price of bread all you need to do is
simply call the dictionary using the key
bread
this makes it extremely easy to track
values through your code since you're
working with tangible values rather than
numbers which don't mean anything to you
you can also manipulate dictionaries in
many of the same ways you can manipulate
arrays and array lists you can iterate
through a dictionary and perform many
operations and comparisons on the values
if you want to find the product with the
highest price for example you can
iterate through the dictionary to find
the value that is highest amongst the
grocery store items
arrays array lists and dictionaries are
useful in their own right as are the
mass amounts of other ways to store data
and each post certain advantages over
one another we already covered the
basics of these three but since there
are so many we don't have time to go in
depth into each and every one of them
and so in order to help you grasp the
basics of storing information we're now
going to talk about one of the most
important functions needed to understand
arrays which are searching algorithms
now just as there are many ways to store
information in computer science there
are even more ways of searching through
lists searching algorithms at their core
are ways in which we can look through a
list of values stored in an array say a
patient name list or a high score list
and find a particular piece of data
the goal of a searching algorithm is
simply to give the algorithm a string or
object you want it to find and have it
return the index of the array that
contains that string or object as fast
as possible
now while this may seem simple lots of
software runs on the backbone of being
able to search through lists extremely
quickly making searching algorithms and
in particular efficient searching
algorithms an important topic to cover
additionally this is the main
functionality that arrays are used for
and is the backbone of many of the
methods used within arraylists as well
as many other storage methods so knowing
them will take you a very long way
typically searching algorithms are used
to return the index of a particular data
point so that it can be used modified
updated or checked on
for example if you're about to check
into a hospital run on an array system
for patients the staff must search
through your name in the database and by
returning the index of where your name
is they now have a quantifiable number
that they can use to easily check you in
rent out prescriptions schedule you for
checkups update your personal
information etc without having to search
through the list for your name every
single time
you may think that there's little
difference between searching algorithms
since computers nowadays can perform
millions of calculations per second but
when you're a huge multi-billion dollar
corporation trying to find a certain
data point in a list containing
thousands or even millions of data
points small differences in efficiency
are going to make or break the user
experience even a one percent
improvement in efficiency can mean a big
differences in the amount of time that a
user is waiting for a simple task
now before we jump into different types
of searching algorithms we must discern
between the two states that a razor list
can be in either sorted or unsorted
a sorted list of information is
characterized by some sort of rankable
value whether that be a patient id
credit card number or even by
alphabetical values like usernames or
legal names an unsorted list is just
some random assortment of related
information not sorted by any particular
order or reason
some searching algorithms only work for
sorted lists usually the more efficient
ones and some work for both sorted and
unsorted lists
although these are usually less
efficient if you end up pursuing
computer science further you'll have to
deal with both sorted and unsorted lists
so it's good to know a common searching
practice for both
another thing to note is that we would
determine the efficiency of searching
algorithms based on both the worst case
scenario and the average number of items
it must search in order to find the
index we call this big o notation in
which each searching algorithm has an
equation which takes in the size of the
array as an integer n and will output a
worst case scenario efficiency value
that we can use to compare with other
searching algorithms
we can then also look at how long on
average it takes to find an element in a
list
using these two methods allows us to
easily compare how efficient two
algorithms are
alright now that we've got some
background on searching algorithms let's
hop right into it
the first type of search we'll be
talking about is called a linear search
and you've honestly probably used this
multiple times throughout your life
every time you have to search for your
name on a list of people you probably
follow the same pattern you start at the
top check to see if the first name on
the list is yours if it is great if not
you move on to the next name on the list
until either you find your name or you
don't in which case you leave
a linear search works in the same way
you start with the first element in the
list compare it to the value that you're
trying to find and if they're the same
you found your match and you return the
index of that element
and if not you move on to the next
element in the list until you either
find the thing you're searching for or
you run out of lists to check
pretty simple right this is because
linear searches are pretty bad when it
comes to efficiency especially in the
worst case scenario if the item you're
searching for in the list is the last
element you're going to have to check
the entire list of items before you find
the one you're searching for
on average however you're going to get
it about halfway through the list this
makes the linear search of n worst case
scenario since in the worst possible
case it will take the entire length of
the array or n to find the correct value
the linear search on average will return
the correct index in o of n divided by 2
we're halfway through the list
now while the linear search isn't great
it can work with both sorted and
unsorted lists
because of the fact that it will
eventually cover every element in the
list
the other search we're going to cover
requires the list to be sorted which may
seem like a drawback but having a sorted
list allows you to use algorithms that
are far more efficient than the linear
search
so overall the linear search is a good
basic searching algorithm for if you
have an unsorted list but if your list
is sorted there are way more efficient
options out there for you such as the
binary search which we'll be talking
about now
the binary search uses a recursive
process to break the data in your list
down into more and more manageable bytes
taking advantage of the fact that it's
sorted in order to find the item you're
looking for faster
this one is much harder to wrap your
head around so let's start with an
example
let's say you have a list of 10 names
sorted alphabetically like shown on the
screen now and you wanted to find your
name within that list
in binary search you would look for the
middle most name in this case the one at
the fourth index
just a quick aside since there is no
true middle since the list is 10 names
long
the computer automatically uses the next
one down as the middle value
now once you find your middle value you
first check to see if the name you're
searching for at the index you've chosen
is the name that you're looking for
if it is you simply return that index
but 99 of the time it's not going to be
including right now so let's keep going
if the value at the middle name is not
equal to the one you're searching for
you check to see if the value you're
searching for comes before or after the
middle index
for example if you were looking for the
name brendan and the value at the middle
index was carl
brendan obviously comes before carl
alphabetically and since we know that
the list is sorted what we can now do is
ignore the entire bottom half of the
list and just focus on the top since we
know that if brendan is even in the list
it's going to be in that top half
now we simply treat the top half of the
list as an entirely new entity and
repeat the process over again
again we would find the middle most
element of this new list of names and
again compare to the name you're trying
to find
if it's the name we're trying to find we
return that index but if not we compare
it to see if it comes before or after
the middle index
going back to our example let's say the
middle index of this new list is aj
now we know that brennan comes after aj
alphabetically so what we can now do is
ignore the top half of the list since we
know that if brennan is in the list it's
not going to be in the top half of our
list
now we again repeat this process again
and again until we find the name we are
looking for so for our example the
middle index's time is brendon and
that's what we're searching for so
finally we would return the index to
in binary search eventually the index we
would compare to our search term will be
the same and once it is we can return
the index and move on
now if we don't find it which happens
after we have eliminated the entirety of
the list without finding our search term
the algorithm will simply return a null
value to let you know that the item
you're searching for cannot be found in
the list
the binary search is way faster and more
efficient than the linear search since
we are drastically cutting down the
amount of elements we have to look at
making the program run faster
in almost 99.9 percent of cases in which
your list is sorted the binary search is
going to return a result faster than the
linear search
so if you have a sorted list your best
option is to go for binary
as for efficiency the binary search is o
log n for the worst case scenario which
could be confusing if you don't fully
understand logarithms but all you need
to know is that it is way more efficient
than the linear search
its average scenario is actually also o
log n as well which again is infinitely
times more efficient than the linear
cases
now while there are other types of
searching algorithms you can use these
two are the most common for both
unsorted and sorted lists so we will
stop there for now
up next we're going to be covering one
of the most confusing and important
topics in computer science recursion
let's start with the most important
question
what exactly does recursion mean
in programming recursion refers to
functions that repeatedly call
themselves
meaning that in the instructions that
occur within a function one of the
instructions will be a call to that same
function you're already in
in the extremely primitive example on
your screen now you can see we have some
function which in the confines of itself
calls itself a recursive function will
usually take into account some integer
as an argument and we'll use this to
carry out some instructions modifying
the integer that was entered before
calling itself again with that new
integer as its argument to better
understand these functions let's discuss
the basics of how we go about
programming one of them
a really good and easy example of a
recursive function is one which sums up
all numbers from 1 to n so let's make a
recursive function that does just that
the first thing we need is the actual
function and we're going to make it an
integer function which takes an integer
n as its argument the reason we do this
will be explained later but for now
let's move on to the base case a base
case is simply a definite value which
all recursive statements the ones that
are being repeatedly called as we go
through the function try to get towards
at the beginning of the function we test
the value that was passed in by the
argument against the base case to see if
it is satisfied
usually these base cases are some
requirements like if n as i described
before which is a certain value or is
equal to a certain value it is extremely
important that the base case is set to
some requirement that n will eventually
meet for the same reason that it is
important to avoid an infinite loop we
do not want a stack overflow error to
occur
for example if our base case was to stop
calling the recursive function when n
was greater than 100 and if it is not we
will call the same function again but
with n minus 1 and we started with n as
say 99 we would never reach the base
case and the recursive function will
repeatedly call itself over and over
again subtracting 1 from n and hoping
that somehow it will eventually be
greater than 100 until your computer
crashes
not fun
so anyways back to our recursive sum
example
let's make our base case when n is less
than or equal to one
this way we can start at some positive
integer n and subtract from it until it
is less than or equal to one in which
case we can exit the recursive statement
cool
now if n is not less than or equal to
one
what we want to do is return the sum of
both n
and then the returning value of our
recursive sum method -1
why do we add and end the function call
well let's actually go through the
function as if we were the computer and
see why
we start with a call of recursive sum
with n equals three we know that three
is not less than or equal to one so now
we try to return a recursive sum of n
which is three and the returning value
of recursive sum with an n of 2.
we don't know what the returning value
of recursive sum with an n of 2 is so we
have to go through the function again
only this time n is 2.
again
n is not less than or equal to one
and so this function will go through the
else statement and return
two plus another recursive statement in
this case the returning value of
recursive sum with an n of one
so once again we have to go through the
recursive sum function to get that value
that will be added to 2 and then
returned and added to 3 and then
returned
hang in there we're close
now in this function
n is less than or equal to one and so we
return n which is one
now we take that n
which again is one
and that is what gets added to two in
the previous function call and then
returned
so this would return three
now this three is what gets added to the
first function call which is three and
so it becomes three plus three which is
six
and finally after all that time we get
six return from the function
which if you've been following along at
home three plus two plus one is indeed
six
now this may seem like a waste of time
since three plus two plus one is not a
hard operation
but to those of you saying that i ask
you to please give me the sum of all the
numbers from 1 to 3567
godspeed
now recursion is a very difficult
concept to wrap your head around so if
you're not 100 comfortable with it at
the moment feel free to re-watch this
section of the video in order to better
familiarize yourself with it
all right cool now that we have a little
background on recursion let's talk about
why it works so well
now to understand why and how recursion
works we must first understand what a
stack is
a stack is a data structure that
contains all of the tasks you instruct
your program to complete
based on a certain method your program
will then carry out the tasks you give
it it's called a stack because if we
start another process before the
previous one completes the process is
stacked on top of the other one such as
the animation on your screen is showing
now
programs we write will follow the lethal
structure
for those unfamiliar with accounting
lifo means last in first out or the last
item put on the stack will be the first
one removed from it
essentially every time you ask your
computer to complete a task that task is
added to this deck and will be the first
one to be resolved think of it like a
stack of stones you can keep adding
stones on top of your pile but in order
to get to the one at the bottom you must
first remove all the rocks on top of it
now when your function continually calls
itself without end without a base case
like in our infinite loop example then
the stack will never be resolved as
items will be continually added to the
stack without any of them ever being
completed in this case the memory
allocated to the stack exceeds the
maximum allowed and a stack overflow
error occurs resulting in your program
crashing
think of this as if you're doing chores
and before you complete one chore you
get called to do another chore and then
before you can complete that one you get
called to do another one since you keep
stacking tasks or chores on top of one
another the stack of tasks will never be
completed and you will probably die
before ever finishing all of your chores
this is the same logic that makes
infinite loops crash your program
recursion works on these same principles
the initial call makes a second call
which is added to the stack and now that
one must be taken care of first but in
that one another function is called
which gets added to the stack and so on
until you reach the base case in which
you slowly start going back down the
stack
in conclusion recursion in general is
extremely useful because by calling the
same functions repeatedly it breaks down
the problem into smaller sections and
results in the program being more
efficient
small parts of problems are easier to
solve and less taxing to compute than
the entire problem at once and the
computer can combine these small
solutions into the whole solution at the
end
now as we wind down our introduction to
programming series we want to take some
time and go over some of the soft skills
needed to be a successful computer
scientist since it's not all about
writing code
in fact many professional computer
scientists will tell you that the
majority of their job is spent thinking
about code rather than actually writing
it
this is because much of programming
boils down to problem solving how do we
optimize this system how can we make
this feature for our app what type of
movement do we want for our game and how
can we program it
the harsh truth is that no good program
has ever been written simply from the
programmer getting the prompt or idea
sitting down hopping on an ide and
starting to write code there are many
tasks we should go through beforehand in
order to plan out our code so we ensure
that when the time comes to program it's
a clean and easy process and not riddled
with mistakes and bugs
this is where pseudo code comes into
play
think of pseudocode like this if you
wanted to take a family trip to the
grand canyon would you simply hop in
your car and drive off and figure out
things later
no because that would be ridiculous
instead you would spend some time
planning out the trip what sites or
places do you want to visit what hotel
reservations are you going to have to
make what kinds of things are you going
to do when you get there what routes or
highways are you going to take and why
all of these things must be determined
before you can even think about hobbing
in your ford explorer
so how does this translate to pseudocode
well think of our family trip to the
grand canyon as a program
programmers use pseudocode pseudo
meaning not real and code meaning code
as a means to plan out their programs
before they write them just like how we
planned out our trip before going
they throw away syntax and naming
conventions for variables and just focus
on what they want the program to
accomplish and how they plan on doing
that
pseudocode is very similar to
constructing an outline for a paper that
you're writing you write down the main
topics of the essay and plan out your
major talking points but you don't worry
about the nitty-gritty details of it all
such as word choice grammar conventions
and proper formatting
by doing this we allow ourselves to
think freely and not worry about
stressing the small stuff at least not
yet
all right now that we know what
pseudocode is let's talk about how we
write pseudocode
you see the best part about pseudocode
is that it can take the form of many
different things for many different
people
each computer scientist has their own
methodology for planning out their code
and there are probably hundreds of
different methods of writing pseudocode
that are out there today
today however i'd like to focus on three
popular ones that i think you might find
to be extremely useful
the first of these is known as
flowcharts and mainly they can be used
to think through the process of a
particular function
a flowchart is fundamentally a graphical
representation of a function and how it
might flow
many programmers do this and lay out the
conditional statements and loops that
they want as different blocks in the
flowchart connected by arrows and
charting out every path of their
function
from there it's extremely easy to create
test cases and follow them through the
flow of the function through the
different blocks and arrows for example
we could have a flowchart that goes
something like this
a user enters in a number and if the
number is 8 i want the program to return
true
however if the number is not 8 then i
want it to return false
it's a great way to visualize what the
function's overall purpose is and also
look for any errors that you may have
missed when thinking about the function
such as a missing path
it also abstracts the programming
statements up to simple blocks making it
easier to modify or change completely
the best part is that when you have
finished testing cases you can simply
convert the blocks into programming
statements and you have a well-written
function without any debugging
another popular pseudo code technique
that is often used is to simply write
out what you want your code to do
chronologically
don't necessarily think about what
programming statements and functions you
want to use just jot down from start to
finish what it is the program you you're
writing is going to do step by step
for example let's say you're making an
app that takes in two numbers and
divides them the pseudo code for that
would look a little something like this
first i want to prompt the user to enter
a number and then i want to wait for the
user to enter in that first number
after i get the first number i want to
again prompt the user to input a second
number
once they do i complete the operation by
defining the two numbers entered and
returning the result back to the user
this all seems like it would be common
sense but remember that oftentimes we're
not going to be working with simple
multiplication or division functions
we may be working with full scale games
algorithms or user interfaces with many
different options
this method allows you the programmer to
not get bogged down with the syntax and
conventions that you have to follow
you're simply making a note of what the
program's ultimate goal should be
as if you were explaining it to a friend
of yours this method really lets you
plan out everything that needs to happen
in your program in order for it to run
smoothly
it also ensures you don't forget about a
piece of an algorithm or a certain
function that you need to write in
afterwards
and the final pseudo code strategy that
i'd like to talk about to you today is
writing out the main features you want
the user to have when using your program
and what functions or smaller programs
you're going to need to complete these
features
let's do another example
say you're making a banking interface
and on startup you want the user to
initially have two options
they can set up a new account or log
into an existing account
from there if they log into their
account then you want them to have the
functionality to withdraw money deposit
money take out a loan or pay back a loan
if they decide to set up a new account
you want them to be able to create an
account store their information in a
database and then access all of the
features that a returning member would
have
this may look very similar to the
flowchart method the only difference
being that this is abstracted one level
higher over an entire program rather
than just a single function
if you really wanted to you could also
create a flowchart that would go through
the functionality of all the four
methods described above
setting up a hierarchy like seeing on
your screen now makes it easy and clear
to see every function and interface
you're going to have to make this
prevents you from having to try to
shoehorn a function or feature into an
already finished program at the last
second which is not a very fun
experience in the slightest
so there you have it three pseudo code
strategies you can use to plan out your
code before you even start writing any
the flowchart method which is good for
thinking through the flow of a certain
function the write-up method which is
good for getting the general idea down
for a program or the functionality
planning method good for listing out the
functions of a certain program you can
use all of them none of them a mixture
of them or even disregard these and find
and create your own pseudo code methods
the main goal here is to drastically
minimize the amount of errors that occur
during your program and relieve a lot of
stress on your head
the importance of pseudo code cannot be
stressed enough and if you don't believe
me i urge you to try to complete a large
project without it
okay so if you've watched the series up
until this point you've gotten a pretty
good understanding of many aspects of
programming and also how to plan out
your programs now it's time to go out
into the real world and write some
actual code
but what kind of program i can hear you
asking me and the answer is truly
whatever you want really
as i'm sure you know by now you can
program just about anything you have on
your mind anything from simple games to
complex software this video has equipped
you with the basics that are going to
need to be used in pretty much any
program you decide to write but that
doesn't mean that every programming
language is perfect for every
application
each language has its own strengths and
weaknesses and choosing the right one is
very important for making it easier and
sometimes just even possible for you to
program what you want so that's what we
are going to be talking about now
choosing the best language for what you
want to accomplish
now we talked earlier about low-level
versus high-level programming languages
in case you forgot let's do a quick
refresher higher level programming
languages have a higher level of
abstraction from machine language that
series of zeros and ones from way back
when while lower level programming
languages have a low level of
abstraction for machine language for
example block programming where you can
drag and drop programming statements
together like 2d legos would be a high
level language as it does not take a
high level of understanding of the inner
workings of a computer to program it
the theoretical highest level of a
programming language would be if i could
just write down what i wanted the
computer to do in simple english and it
would just work
but sadly that doesn't exist yet
on the other side of the spectrum the
lowest level programming language would
be just feeding zeros and ones into the
computer at supersonic speed which would
be almost impossible and extremely
absurd
so
how do you choose what type of language
is best for your needs
well it depends on what you are trying
to do as sometimes you need very
specialized languages to get done what
you want
the world of computer science is vast
and contains many fields so trying to
cover everything in one language would
be impossible
this has led to the creation of hundreds
of different programming languages each
designed for a specific task
right now though we'll cover some of the
most popular languages and their uses
now if you are trying to design a
website using html and css is probably
your best bet
html is a markup language that is
designed for writing the content of a
website while css is great for designing
the style of the website
you interact with html every day and you
can even see it right now if you right
click and hit inspect element this will
truly show you how complex html and css
can be maybe it would be best for you to
use a scripting language a scripting
language is a language that has many
commands for you to use and that can
also be run without needing to be
compiled
scripts can be faster to write than most
programs and tend to be easier to port
between operating systems allowing for
cross-platform support
scripts can also be used with websites
oftentimes adding to the overall user
experience of the site
if you want to go into web design this
might also be a path for you to go down
examples of scripting languages are
pearl php ajax and javascript
for most programs you could probably use
a general purpose language
general purpose languages as they sound
have a wide range of applications
usually these should be your go-to
languages
examples of general purpose languages
are java c plus plus and python
they each have their own different
benefits over one another java is very
useful for developing games and
interactive web pages
python can act as a scripting language
for web programming as well as writing
applications and data analysis
and c plus plus tends to be used for
writing applications and system programs
they all have a variety of packages that
you can import and use to achieve the
functionality you need from them
while selecting the right general
purpose language for your big projects
is very important for most of your
programs any one of them will work it
really comes down to preference get to
know each language and decide which ones
syntax rules you like best and find most
comfortable
if you get to know one general purpose
language really well and enjoy
programming with it you can apply to
just about any of the programs you plan
on writing
personally i tend to use python for most
of my projects this is mostly not due to
any functional difference between python
and any other general purpose language
though there are a few but it is mainly
because i find its syntax rules most
convenient and easiest to write programs
with
overall either you can consider the
product you plan on doing and research
and see which language boasts the most
advantages for your purposes
or you can simply become comfortable
with a language and use it for most of
the programs you decide to write
we'll now be looking at our final topic
of this introduction to programming
miniseries you now have the basic
knowledge of programming which will take
you far in any language that you decide
to learn you know some good
pre-programming pseudo code strategies
to help you design your code from the
ground up and you might already have a
good idea as to the type of programming
language you might want to start with so
what's the next step
how can i learn that language and what
applications can it be used for
well that's what we're going to be
covering now so let's just jump right
into it
starting with the biggest question which
is what is the next step
well now that you might know which type
of language you might be interested in
research that language and find out
whether or not you truly want to pursue
that programming language
most languages like python or c plus
will have either an official website
where you can read up on the language or
a wikipedia page which will provide you
with useful information in deciding
whether or not you want to pursue that
path
from there the next step is to actually
learn the language which can be done
right here on youtube while we've taught
you the basics of any programming
language each specific language is going
to expand upon these concepts and so
watching tutorial videos on a certain
language is going to be very beneficial
i would start with an introduction
series like the one you're currently
watching but for the language you have
chosen and work your way through that
series picking up on the syntax and
rules of that language until you become
comfortable with it
once you do that you come to a
crossroads you know how to program in a
certain language but you may be
completely clueless as to what to make
in that language
programmer's block can leave you
uninspired and not want to continue
programming so i'd like to give you a
few websites to help out
first is codingbat a completely free
website which has hundreds of coding
challenges in both java and python to
help you refine your programming skills
and even learn some new programming
shortcuts and tips
this is great if you want to get better
at improving your efficiency and need
something to hone your skills as a
developer
the next is coderbite which offers over
200 plus challenges that you can
complete in over 10 different languages
something that is sure to help you
improve
the final website i'd like to talk about
is hacker rank which not only provides
programming challenges to keep you on
your toes but also provide support for
you using your programming skills to
find jobs or internships these and many
more websites exist solely to keep you
interested in code and work on refining
your skills to become better now if
you're a teenager watching this series
in high school i also encourage you to
take programming classes in your high
school
ap computer science principles and ap
computer science a are both amazing
courses which can help you greatly in
the future and are also incredibly
informative and important to colleges
your school might also offer other
classes in the field of computer science
including ones on data structures game
design and data science
any and all classes you can take to help
expand your knowledge of programming and
help you find your niche is going to be
extremely helpful
as you can see the world of code has now
been opened up to you these are just a
few examples of where you can go from
here but there are many more we didn't
talk about you could get into github and
start contributing to projects you could
work on your own projects and
collaborate with others the
possibilities are endless the next step
is up to you
this concludes our introduction to
programming miniseries we hope you
enjoyed watching it as much as we
enjoyed making it
if you enjoyed the series as a whole
consider subscribing to our channel no
pointer exception which will be linked
in the description for more content like
this coming soon
thank you so much for watching